previously on the divine comedy
dante entered the gates of hell
accompanied by his guide
virgil together they passed through the
nine circles of hell
and escaped eternal damnation dante's
hell was divided into
nine circles each one representing a
specific
sin as you descend deeper the crimes and
punishments in theory worsen
purgatory is divided into nine or ten
levels depending on your interpretation
the first two are known as
anti-purgatory
the next seven are known as the terraces
each terrace representing one of the
seven deadly sins or vices
which can only be cleansed with the
seven holy virtues
the last level is known as the earthly
paradise
on the morning of easter sunday dante
and virgil stand at the very bottom
of the mountain of purgatory
if you thought dante's descent through
hell was a crazy journey
it's now time to begin our ascent of
mount purgatory
today's video has been made possible by
the great courses plus
if you enjoy learning new things whether
it's in the form of a lecture
an online course or even just an
interesting documentary
then the great courses plus is the
streaming platform for you
their extensive library of over 11 000
courses lectures and documentaries
means there is always something
interesting to watch
the courses themselves are presented by
ivy league professors from
all around the world with a wide range
of topics from science
history and philosophy to finance food
and travel
there are no limits to how much you can
watch and it's available
on pretty much every device as you
patiently wait for part three of the
divine comedy to be released
you can watch the divine comedy lecture
on the great courses plus
which gives you over 12 hours of
information and valuable context
if you'd like to try the great courses
plus for yourself then visit
thegreatcoursesplus.com
mythology that's thegreatcoursesplus.com
mythology or you can click on the link
in the description to start your free
trial today
[Music]
[Music]
before we begin a brief explanation into
the idea of purgatory itself
may provide some context the bible
doesn't really mention purgatory
at least not by name but it does mention
that one's punishment after death may
not always be eternal
in some cases it may only be temporary
once your debt has been repaid
there is hope of one day joining others
in paradise
to explain as simply as possible both
hell and paradise are what dante
considers
eternal realms purgatory is different as
it's the only realm that is not eternal
those who come here may not be ready for
hell or paradise
instead they are given the chance to
cleanse their sins and grow as a person
when it's time for the last judgement
all the souls in purgatory will be sent
to either hell or paradise and the realm
of purgatory will cease to exist
entirely
at the base of the mountain dante and
virgil meet an old man named
cato who guards the entrance naturally
he's hesitant to let them pass
not entirely sure how dante and virgil
were able to escape from hell
virgil explains the journey thus far and
how it would only be possible for them
to escape if god himself
allowed them to kato is persuaded
and allows them to pass but only if
virgil wraps a reed around dante and
washes his face
a ritual many soras representing a
baptism
an interesting thing to note is that
kato is what we described before
as a virtuous pagan who was placed in
purgatory by god himself
which is rather strange because not only
could he be found in the first
circle of hell but he also committed
suicide
i've seen many discussing the
significance of kato in purgatory
so why would dante place kato here in
purgatory
and not in hell it could be because keto
was as patriotic as dante and would do
anything to defend rome's liberty or
maybe dante was just fond of kato and
decided he shouldn't suffer
in the first circle of hell souls are
ferried across the river by the boatman
carron some of them crying and others
with
looks of worry and anguish on their face
here they are ferried to the foot of the
mountain by an angel
whilst singing songs of hope and joy
when they arrive at the shore the angel
disappears and the crowd gathers around
dante
realizing he's not actually dead luckily
kato breaks up the crowd
and orders them to disperse the two
stand at the base of the mountain
deciding how they will begin their climb
as a group of souls pass by the first
two sections of the mountain
are known as anti-purgatory
the first slope is where they find the
excommunicate
those who are excluded or exiled from
the christian church
the time they spent away from the church
living in sin
would be multiplied by 30 so if they
spent even just
one year excommunicated they would have
to remain here for 30.
the most noticeable figure they meet
here is manfred
the last king of sicily who tells them
the story of his death
during the battle of benevento he
suffered multiple
fatal wounds whilst he lay on the
battlefield dying he managed to repent
for all of his sins unfortunately for
manfred his opposition
pope clement iv had his body
excommunicated
after death which led to the belief that
he was going to hell
manfred then explains that the prayers
of the living can help reduce the time
one
spends in purgatory naturally he asks
dante
to find his daughter when he returns to
let her know her father
is not in hell but in purgatory if she
prays for him
he may reach paradise quicker before
reaching the terraces there is still
one more part of anti-purgatory for
those who were too late
or too lazy to repent many of these
souls died before receiving the last
rites
because they suffered a violent or
unpredictable death
dante comes across a group of souls
laying in the shadow of a boulder
and decides to have a conversation the
first man tells him he was betrayed when
fleeing his hometown
the second man was fleeing a battle when
he fell down a riverbed
and died after repenting the man recalls
an
angel coming to collect him but there
was also a demon
they argued whether he belonged in hell
or paradise
and that is why he now finds himself in
purgatory
the last spirit was a woman named pia de
tolemay
she tells dante of her murder at the
hands of her husband
who betrayed her and disregarded their
wedding vows
she also attempts to convince dante to
pray for her once he returns to the
living
because none of her family do so and she
would like to leave
purgatory dante begins to notice how
interested
all the souls in purgatory are in
himself or more so the fact
that he is not dead meaning he can pray
for them
and reduce the time they spend here the
next soul they meet
is sordello a performer from the same
town as virgil
who explains the rule of the mountain
once the sun has set
the souls of purgatory are no longer
allowed to climb
they can go down if they wish to rest
but never the other way
you can look at the sun as an allegory
for god meaning these souls can only
progress
in their penitent christian life through
his divine grace
as it is getting late in the afternoon
they move on
and find a spot to rest sordello
recommends they should stop for the
night
in the valley of princes as darkness in
gulsta valley the spirits sing hymns you
would hear during night prayer in
christian churches
sodelo shows them the various kings and
rulers who reside here
making notes of emperor rudolph the only
soul who refuses to join in
on the singing he also regards him as
the one ruler who could have restored
italy to its former glory
but he failed and that is why he finds
himself here
as the night goes on the spirits here do
not tire as they do not possess a human
body
dante however does and so he must sleep
in his dream dante sees a golden eagle
soaring through the sky
it swoops down and grabs dante and while
they fly through the air they begin to
burn
this was enough for dante to wake from
his dream
virgil explains that they are now at the
gate of purgatory
whilst dante dreamt he was carried to
the gates by a woman named
lucia this is referring to saint lucia
or saint
lucy in front of them is the gate
the door to purgatory proper before the
gate there are three steps
each one a different color one is a
polished
white marble so bright dante can see
himself in the reflection
this represents the purity of one soul
the next stone is cracked and much
darker
either black or purple in the shape of a
cross
which represents the act of mourning the
last stone is red
which represents the blood of christ
restoration
and a new beginning at the top of these
steps there is an angel
guarding the entrance wielding a large
sword
an angel who shines so bright it's
difficult for dante to even look at him
virgil explains they have been guided
upon this patch by saint
lucy and he urges dante to step forward
and ask the angel to let him pass
dante opts for the more dramatic
approach as he climbs
the steps he falls to his knees at the
feet of the angel
and begs for entry into purgatory
looking down at dante the angel takes
the point of his sword
and carves the letter p into dante's
forehead seven
times the p meaning pecan
the latin for sin he tells dante he may
wash these wounds away
as he travels through the seven terraces
each time he has successfully washed
away the sins of a terrorist
one letter will disappear the last piece
of advice they are given is to cleanse
themselves of their sins and never look
back or dwell on the past as they may
struggle to move on to the next terrace
with the gates closing behind them the
poets are left to climb the seven
terraces
each one representing one of the seven
deadly sins
pride envy wrath
sloth avarice gluttony and lust
the sins we saw in inferno were based on
physical actions
in purgatory the focus is on
self-improvement
and so the sins are emotional and
psychological
the first terrace represents the sin of
pride
as they enter dante notices beautiful
sculptures surrounding him
which represented humility the virtue
considered the opposite of pride
these images were of individuals who
were considered classic examples of
humility such as the virgin mary and the
angel gabriel
virgil pulls dante away from the
beautiful sculptures and paintings
because in front of them are the
prideful souls who can guide them to the
next terrace
these souls are barely visible as they
are hunched over
forced to carry enormous weights on
their back
they ask the man before them if he can
help them travel
up the mountain the man physically
cannot look
upwards but he tells them he will offer
his assistance
his name is omberto a man who was so
proud it led to his death his arrogance
caused himself
and his family much pain but now he is
slowly learning to be humble
ahead of him is another man odurissi
a once famous artist who was replaced by
a much
younger artist he now understands that
in the bigger picture human fame means
nothing
success and fame are fleeting as dante
talks to these souls he finds himself
bending over to see their faces in doing
so he is
imitating their suffering and starting
his own cleansing process
as they continue on dante realizes that
pride is a
sin he has been guilty of his
self-awareness is another sign of
self-improvement
when he looks down he sees several
hideous statues and carvings
lucifer falling from the heavens arachne
who was turned into a spider
embryos a giant impaled on a
thunderbolt these figures all represent
the acts of succumbing to pride or one's
ego as he witnesses more dante remembers
instances where his own pride has
clouded his judgment
agreeing to pray for the souls in this
terrace they show him the path he must
follow
when they arrive standing before them is
the angel
of humility he takes them to the
stairway that leads to the next terrace
and acknowledges that dante's prideful
sins have been absorbed
with his wing he brushes off one of the
letter p's from dante's forehead
as they leave this terrace they hear
songs of joy
and dante points out the difference
between this and the screams in hell
whenever they entered a new circle he
also notices he feels lighter
making the ascent slightly easier than
before
virgil explains that this is because his
sins of pride
have been cleansed and as this process
continues the journey will become
easier the second terrace is that of
envy
once there dante and virgil noticed no
one else around them
and so virgil uses the sun as a compass
to guide them
when they eventually come across other
souls dante notices they are dressed in
black and blue
matching the colour of the stone in this
terrace
as they approach they hear these souls
singing and
holding onto each other it is now dante
sees their true punishment
the reason their hands rest on the
shoulders of the soul in front of them
is because they are blind their eyelids
have been sewn
shut using iron wire this sight is
enough to bring dante to tears
as he is reminded of the blind begging
on the streets
despite virgil's disapproval dante still
feels a need to speak with them
and so he asks if any are from italy
a woman named sapia responds telling him
she
often received more enjoyment from the
misfortune of others than her
own good fortune she was extremely
envious of those in power
when she questions dante as to who he is
and why he's still alive
he tells her he will pass through this
terrace and only be momentarily blinded
because he felt he was more prideful
than envious
sapi agrees to guide them through the
terrace in exchange for dante's prayers
back on earth to dante's amusement two
souls in front of him
argue amongst each other before they
notice him observing
one of which tells him he was jealous of
his neighbor's happiness
and his envy only grew as time went on
as they continue dante hears the booming
of several different voices
these are the envious who are punished
serving as examples for the rest of the
souls to learn from
some examples given were kane who was
jealous of his brother
and aguarus who was turned into stone
because she was jealous hermes loved her
sister more than her
in order to pass through this terrace
dante and virgil must walk where the sun
shines
bright and as they do they are blinded
mimicking the punishment of those in
this terrace
virgil explains that dante should not
fear this light
because it is merely an angel coming to
welcome them to the next terrace
the angel of charity greets them and
brushes away
another sin from dante's forehead
inviting them to move on
as the poets enter the terrace of wrath
the blinding sunlight is still apparent
dante is then greeted by several visions
examples of meekness
and wrath the first vision is in a
temple with a woman reprimanding a young
boy
this is meant to represent a similar
story featuring the virgin
mary and a young jesus christ
the next vision is the wife of the king
of athens begging him to kill the man
who loves their daughter
his response is no if they condemn those
around them for showing love
then they will soon be their enemies the
last vision is of a boy who prays for
his persecutors to be forgiven by god
as they stone him to death when dante
comes to
he explains what he has seen to virgil
hoping this will start the process of
cleansing his own sins relating to wrath
the current time is 3pm the poets
continue to follow the light up the
mountain
until they are surrounded by black smoke
which now blinds them
dante compares himself to a blind man
being guided by virgil
unable to see dante hears more singing
one voice calls out to dante recognizing
that he's alive
and in response dante and virgil ask for
directions
the spirit agrees and tells the poets to
listen carefully
because their voices are the only way to
keep track of each other within the
smoke
the spirit's name is marco lombardo
dante asks him why he believes there is
wickedness in the world
marco explains he thinks it's because of
the belief that humanity has no free
will
when something terrible happens people
look to the heavens as the cause
the action must have been preordained by
god
but marco believes we must have free
will over some actions
otherwise the reward and punishment
system of heaven and hell makes no
sense you can't punish or reward someone
for an action they are not responsible
for
that being said marco believes he came
from a time where the morals of men
were much greater than dante's present
day
eventually the smoke begins to clear and
this is marco's cue to leave before the
angel of this terrace arrives
before leaving dante has several more
visions that represent
the sin of wrath he's woken by virgil as
the sun
shines bright on them from the light
they hear a voice
telling them it's time to ascend to the
next terrace
as dante approaches intrigued as to the
source of this beautiful voice
he is once again blinded the voice they
hear
is the angel of this terrace who has
come to guide them
as they climb the steps to the next
terrace the angel removes another sin
from dante
and gives them a blessing by the time
they leave this terrace
night falls upon them as they enter
terrace number four
dante asks virgil which vice is to be
cleansed in this terrace
the answer to that question is sloth
now this doesn't necessarily mean
physical laziness
but more of a spiritual laziness or
neglect
that would lead to someone being sad and
depressed
virgil explains sloth by using love as
an example
he states there are two types of love
we can choose what or who to love and
whether we love them
too little or too much these are
mistakes we can make
the second type of love is love towards
god himself
which can never be a mistake if your
love for god
is your priority then you can never
succumb to evil
however this changes when your love for
god takes a back seat
in virgil's worldview love is the
driving force for all of our actions and
decisions
all of our vices and virtues stem from
love
those guilty of sloth in this case have
given up on the pursuit of love
and have turned their backs on god and
their own happiness
most of the spirits in this terrace
don't have much time to talk to dante
and so virgil guides him through how to
cleanse this
vice as the night goes on dante decides
to get some rest
and begins to dream about a beautiful
woman
this woman is actually a siren the siren
here is a symbol of gluttony
and lust dante is seduced by the siren
song
he doesn't notice the arrival of a
second woman who is dressed much more
saintly this woman doesn't seem too
happy that virgil allowed this situation
to happen
realizing his mistake virgil runs over
to the siren
and tears off her clothes rather than
being in
awe of the naked woman in front of him
dante snaps out of his trance
he smells the siren's putrid stench and
foul appearance
he now sees her true nature
when dante wakes they hurry to the
entrance of the next terrace
and there to greet them is the angel of
zeal
having proven himself in his dream the
angel brushes off another sin
and shows them passage to the next
terrace
the last three terraces are devoted to
those who either misplace their love or
show too much
they are the terraces of avarice
gluttony
and lust terrorist number five relates
to the
vice of avarice meaning greed for
physical goods and extravagance or the
ambition to gain power and social
standing
as they pass through this terrace they
see the penitent souls lying
face down on the ground in chains
weeping
when they ask for directions they are
told if they do not share a
similar punishment then they should look
to the path on the right
the first soul dante speaks to is pope
adrian v
who is here because of his ambition for
political power within the church
eventually he began to lose interest in
his mortal life
and so he began to focus on the
afterlife
which is why he finds himself here and
not in hell
they continue down the path when they
hear a female voice calling out to them
she describes mary giving birth to jesus
in a stable as an example of how poor
she was
this becomes common with other souls
discussing their stories of poverty
soon the poets realize the way to
cleanse the sin of greed
is with generosity dante begins to hear
more stories of generosity
as opposed to avarice fabricius was a
roman politician who refused to take
bribes that would have furthered his own
position
he then hears several stories of someone
who gave money to poor women so they
could afford to get married
the next soul dante comes across is hugh
cape
a king of france who shares some of his
stories
he also tells dante the souls in this
terrorist discuss
acts of generosity during the day and
sins of avarice during the night
all of a sudden the earth begins to
shake and only dante and virgil seem
concerned
so they take this as a sign to make
haste the last man they come across
is compared to jesus christ shortly
after his resurrection
dante and virgil here are the two
disciples he meets on the road
when he questions who they are virgil
explains that dante was meant to reign
with the righteous
but he has fallen off his path and it is
virgil's job to guide him
the man is overjoyed hearing this mostly
because he is a big fan of virgil's work
the man reveals himself as the roman
poet status the tremor they felt
earlier only happens when a soul is
ready to ascend to paradise
on this occasion the tremor is because
of status
status explains it was the work of
virgil that inspired him to change his
ways
the three are then greeted by the angel
of moderation
who removes another of dante's sins and
ushers them to the next terrace
estatius himself will be moving through
the terraces
he decides to join dante and virgil on
their journey
terrace number six is where those guilty
of gluttony reside
as somebody who's covered the story of
tantalus within greek mythology a few
times
what comes next is a very nice reference
the souls in this terrace experience a
punishment
very similar to tantalus eternal hunger
and thirst in front of them is a large
tree ripe with fruit and below a pool of
water
as they approach they begin to hear
voices telling stories of temperance
the virtue dante will need to purge his
gluttony
john the baptist chose to eat locust and
honey when he was in the wilderness
and the virgin mary cared more about her
guest than herself
dante is unable to place where the
voices are coming from
but it seems as if they may be coming
from the tree itself
before he can be tempted by the fruit
virgil urges
dante to continue on the path ahead of
them
now they finally see the souls that
reside in this terrace
dante is horrified by how starved and
skinny they are
their skeletons are almost completely
visible
again dante begins to hear voices
warning him this tree represents the
tree of knowledge that eve ate from in
the garden of eden
they also begin to tell stories of
gluttony
the stories continue as they walk on
eventually they come to a halt when they
see a red light
this is the angel of temperance who
shows them the path they must not stray
from
as dante was able to avoid temptation he
had shown enough temperance
or self-restraint for the angel to
remove the sin
of gluttony now we move on to terrace
number seven
where the lustful reside to enter this
terrace
one must pass through a giant wall of
fire
our poets tread carefully before
reaching the wall here they see other
souls walking through the flames and
giving examples of lust
one of them being the cities of sodom
and gomorrah
cities that were mentioned in the book
of genesis
those repenting here do so for acts of
inappropriate
and misdirected sexual desire to purge
themselves of this sin
they look towards the virgin mary and
chastity
as the sun begins to set the poets are
greeted by the angel of chastity
who urges them to proceed through the
fire but dante remains frozen to the
spot
virgil persuades him that there is
nothing to fear
unlike hell there is no chance of death
here
with this dante shows his faith in god
as well as in virgil
who has led him this far he steps
forward and passes through the wall of
fire
on the other side they are greeted by
another set of steps
which they choose to rest on until
sunrise
when light breaks dante and his two
guides climb to the very top
here virgil congratulates him dante is
now free
he no longer needs a guide he urges
dante to go ahead and explore the
earthly paradise on his own
we then have one final verse from virgil
wait no further word or sign from me
your will is free
erect and whole to act against that will
would be to er
therefore i crown and miter you over
yourself
dante is free from purgatory but he
doesn't know these are the last words he
will ever hear
from the man he considers his guide
mentor
and friend at the very top of mount
purgatory sits the earthly paradise
which is pretty much the garden of eden
a vibrant forest full of greenery and
lush surroundings
that embody the peace of eden before
adam and eve fell from grace
the earthly paradise cantos are
notoriously difficult to completely
understand because much of it is
symbolism
this is where dante must confess all of
his sins
the first person dante comes across is a
young woman
holding flowers singing by a riverbed
when he gets closer he recognizes a song
similar to one sung by demeter when her
daughter persephone leaves for the
underworld during the winter
dante is confused as to why all of a
sudden he can feel the wind on his
cheeks
estatius told him purgatory does not
experience
weather the woman explains that as the
garden of eden
is where humanity committed the original
sin
things here work slightly differently
she also mentions the waters here have
special properties
the power to make one forget all of
their previous
sins or remember all of the good deeds
they have done
when dante turns around both of his
companions are there smiling
a bright flash of light passes through
the forest
and when dante regains his sight he sees
what appears to be
seven trees in the distance as he gets
close he realizes the trees form
a candelabra and the flames from the
candles light the sky
the lights are closely followed by a
group of people all dressed in white
dante describes 24 elders dressed in
white with crowns made from
lilies behind their elders are four
animals wearing crowns made of green
leaves
each with six wings feathers full of
eyes
behind the animals is a chariot being
pulled by a griffin
on the right side there are three
dancing women one dressed in red
one in emerald and the third in white
on the other side there are four more
women dressed in dark red
or purple behind the chariots there are
seven men
two elderly men four humble men
and one man walking alone much of the
divine comedy at times feels like a
lucid dream and you'd be forgiven for
reading this description and having no
idea what is actually happening
it may not be entirely comparable but
processions relating to the church were
fairly common in the roman empire
everything we see in this ritual is
symbolic of something else
much of it borrowing from the new and
old testament
as the chariot comes to a halt angels
rise and cast flowers into the air
from which emerges a woman in a red
dress and white
veil with a crown of olive branches
dante recognizes this as beatrice when
he turns to virgil to tell him he was
right
his friend is no longer there beatrice
symbolizes the path of god
that dante must follow a virgil if you
remember from inferno resides in the
circle for virtuous pagans
he wasn't necessarily a bad person he
just didn't believe in god
in hell and purgatory virgil's guidance
was needed
but now dante must ascend to heaven and
for that he needs a true believer
and so we see virgil pass the torch to
beatrice
dante sheds a tear for his friend who
has taken him this far
but beatrice tells him to cry no more
because of virgil's disappearance
the earthly paradise is no place for
tears or
sorrow dante confesses to beatrice then
after her death
he turned to material belongings to
distract himself from his pain
she then admonishes him claiming her
death should have had the opposite
effect
she continues to push dante to confess
his sinful actions
and he does so feeling more and more
shame
eventually beatrice removes her veil and
dante is so taken back by everything
he just faints when he wakes he finds
himself being placed in the river leafy
by a young woman who along with status
takes him back to beatrice
this is the process of forgetting one's
memories of past sin
the next river he comes to is the river
you know which dante must drink from
in order to restore his memories of all
the good deeds he has done
dante is now ready to ascend to paradise
and the final kanto
ends with these words from that most
holy wave i now return to beatrice
remade as new trees are renewed when
they bring forth
new boughs i was pure and prepared to
climb
unto the stars
now that you've heard dante's journey
through purgatory and
hell there is only one place to visit
but that's a story for another time
and no i don't know when but i will make
you a deal
if this video gets to 50 000 likes then
i'll start working on part three
so you know what to do as always
i've been your host mythology and
fiction explained
[Music]
[Music]
you